Alors ? C'est bien ?
Les fêtes, tout ça, le gras, le sucre, l'alcool, la co- *bip*, les *bip*
Mais lâche-moi putain !
C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon, j'me calme, j'me calme.
Bon. Bref.
Vous avez abusé pendant les fêtes, et comme tous les ans vous avez pris la bonne  résolution
de vous remettre au sport.
Y'a quand même deux ou trois erreurs à ne pas commettre.
Quand on demandait à Winston Churchill le secret de sa bonne santé et de sa longévité,
Il répondait :
"No sport"
Et le fait est qu'il est mort à 90 ans, ce qui était pas mal pour l'époque
Mais par pitié, ne faisons pas de son cas une généralité.
Bah oui, parce que le sport c'est comme tout,
si c'est bien fait, c'est quand même super bon.
Pour la santé.
Donc je ne saurai que trop vous encourager à reprendre le sport.
Si vous en avez envie, bien sûr.
Et comme je suis sympa, je vais vous donner sept conseils pour éviter les erreurs classiques qui transforment une bonne idée en échec.
Voire pire.
Oui, pour commencer et surtout si vous reprenez ça en solo, choisissez un sport que vous maîtrisez.
Vous lancez pas dans des trucs incroyables.
C'est de la gym médiévale !
Paraît qu'ils font tous ça à Hollywood.
Oh, oooh... Aaaaah !
Le jogging, les pompes, les abdos à la maison, le fitness en salle, c'est très bien aussi.
Avant de vous y remettre pour de bon, n'hésitez pas à renforcer un peu les muscles qui soutiennent votre carcasse.
On appelle ça des muscles posturaux.
Être tonique, ça vous évitera pas mal de bobos,
au niveau du dos, par exemple.
Le gainage, c'est pas mal, ou la méthode pilates,
ou toute autre technique qui fait travailler les muscles profonds.
Vous trouverez facilement des exercices à faire sur le web, je vous laisse chercher.
Y'a pas marqué "Julo InShape" là.
Bon allez, OK, je vous mets quand même quelques liens dans la description.
Je vous gâte trop.
Oui alors, un autre point important dans la préparation de votre reprise,
choisissez bien le moment.
Evitez les pics de pollution et les températures extrêmes.
Genre là, après les fêtes, il fait -15°, bah faites plutôt du sport à l'intérieur.
Ah et bien sûr vous fumez pas une heure avant et après l'exercice.
Miminum.
Fumer ça fait baisser le taux d'oxygène dans votre organisme et la nicotine ça accélère le rythme cardiaque.
Et ça c'est bon ni pour vos muscles, ni pour vos coeurs.
Bon allez cette fois c'est bon, vous avez mis votre lycra le plus fluo
et vos organes génitaux sont
♪ moulés comme jamais ♪
Avant de commencer, échauffez-vous.
Oui, oui, tout le monde le sait, mais personne le fait, hein, donc...
Pourtant ça sert ni plus ni moins qu'à préparer à l'effort ses muscles,
ses articulations, mais aussi son coeur et même son esprit,
tout ça en douceur, ce qui évite les traumatismes et les accidents.
Echauffez-vous une dizaine de minutes minimum,
surtout si vous faites du sport le matin ou après une grande période d'inactivité,
et surtout s'il fait froid.
Quand vous faites du sport votre température corporelle augmente
et votre organisme met en place une parade pour lutter contre la surchauffe : la transpiration
Elle peut vous faire perdre entre 500 millilitres et 2 litres et demi d'eau par heure,
ça dépend de l'intensité de votre effort,
et il se trouve que l'eau, c'est le principal composant de notre corps puisqu'elle représente entre 60 et 70% de son poids total
En manquer ça diminue vos performances et ça augmente le risque de crampes, de tendinites et de blessures.
Et quand vous ressentez la soif c'est déjà trop tard alors buvez régulièrement avant et pendant l'exercice.
Et après aussi, tant qu'on y est.
Ah oui et bon, j'ai bien compris, hein,
va y avoir une histoire de régime aussi là dessous,
mais faites attention. diminuer les graisses
Diminuer les graisses, OK.
Diminuer les sucres rapides genre les bonbons, les desserts, d'accord.
Mais votre corps, il a besoin de carburant, hein. Surtout pour faire du sport.
Et notamment de sucres lents, de fibres et de protéines alors allez-y
Alors allez-y.
Se dépenser c'est bien, mais les phases de récupération c'est important pour permettre à vos muscles de se développer
et aussi pour leur permettre de se remettre de l'effort et donc d'éviter les blessures.
Après chaque séance,
prenez le temps de vous étirer et ne faites pas du sport tous les jours.
Gardez-vous quelques jours de repos dans la semaine, surtout au début.
Et dormez.
Faites des vraies nuits de sommeil, c'est important.
Si vous avez déjà fait du sport,
vous étiez peut-être habitué à courir une heure et demie ou à soulever soit 60 kilos au développé-couché,
mais c'était il y a longtemps et votre organisme, bah il a perdu l'habitude.
La force et l'endurance, ça se perd,
donc ayez l'humilité de repartir plus bas que là où vous aviez arrêté.
Si vous êtes complètement noob, faites pas les fous non plus.
Commencez par un petit footing de reprise de 15 minutes, la fois suivante vous passez à 20 minutes,
et vous augmentez progressivement jusqu'à la durée que vous avez envie d'atteindre.
Et après vous augmenterez votre vitesse.
Si vous faites du sport en salle commencez avec des charges légères et des séries avec peu de répétitions
puis augmentez progressivement.
En plus ça vous évitera de vous décourager ou de vous dégoûter.
Vaut mieux commencer petit, augmenter progressivement et s'inscrire dans la durée.
Pour finir de vous convaincre d'y aller doucement, sachez que dans certains cas
trop de sport d'un coup, ça peut tuer.
Sans même parler des problèmes cardiaques.
Là on parle de la rhabdomyolyse.
La rhabdomyolyse, c'est une destruction des fibres musculaires.
Elle peut arriver si un membre reste comprimé trop longtemps
mais aussi après un effort musculaire trop intense ou trop prolongé.
On appelle ça une rhabdomyolyse d'effort, et s'est aggravée par une hydratation insuffisante.
Attention là on parle pas de 20 minutes de jogging ou de dix pompes, hein, faut vraiment forcer.
L'exemple typique, c'est la jeune recrue militaire à qui on fait faire un entraînement intensif pendant toute une journée
et qui a pas le droit de s'arrêter, même s'il a des douleurs.
Oui parce que ça fait mal.
Mais ça peut aussi toucher ceux qui font des courses d'endurance très longues, genre sur plusieurs jours.
Mais il y a aussi des cas qui ont été rapportés chez des amateurs de crossfit.
Ce qu'il se passe, c'est que le muscle est tellement traumatisé par les forts que les fibres musculaires sont détruites
et que les substances produites par leur dégradation se retrouvent dans la circulation sanguine,
et notamment la myoglobine, qui est toxique pour les reins qui peuvent se bloquer.
Parallèlement le taux de potassium augmente dans le sang, on appelle ça une hyperkaliémie,
les reins ne peuvent plus l'éliminer puisqu'ils sont bloqués, et ça peut provoquer un arrêt cardiaque.
Bon, ça c'est des cas rares et extrêmes, OK ?
Avant d'en arriver là y'a des signes qui poussent l'immense majorité des gens à arrêter ce qu'ils sont en train de faire,
genre un coup de fatigue ou des grosses douleurs.
Ce qui nous amène directement au conseil suivant :
Eh oui, pour éviter les ennuis, du plus grave au plus petit, restez à l'écoute de votre corps.
- Oui ?
- J'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim
- C'est l'estomac ?
- j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim
- On... peut se tutoyer ?
- J'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai faim j'ai-
- Oui ?
- Prout ! [rires]
- Ah, c'est l'anus ?
- Tu changes jamais de blagues en fait ?
C'est bien d'écouter tout le monde mais y'a surtout une chose à laquelle il faut être très attentif.
- Oui ?
- Bonjour.
- C'est la douleur.
La douleur c'est un signal d'alarme qui dit : "Attention, il se passe quelque chose de pas bon, là"
Donc soyez-y attentifs.
Si vous avez mal, arrêtez-vous,
et si la douleur persiste, mettez-vous au repos et consultez un médecin.
Ah et d'ailleurs puisqu'on en parle,
si vous avez passé la quarantaine et que vous n'avez pas fait de sport depuis un petit moment,
bah votre médecin, rendez lui une petite visite avant de commencer.
Il vous proposera peut-être un test d'effort,
c'est-à-dire observer votre activité cardiaque pendant une activité sportive.
Genre courir sur un tapis ou faire du vélo.
Déconnez pas avec votre coeur.
Pendant les séances, en cas de douleur ou de sensation de malaise,
arrêtez tout et parlez-en à votre médecin.
Mais il y a des signes qui doivent vous faire réagir beaucoup plus vite.
Si vous ressentez une douleur dans la poitrine
genre ça sert, si ça irradie dans le bras, dans la mâchoire ou dans le dos, si vous êtes essoufflé de façon brutale,
arrêtez la séance et faites appeler le 15.
C'est peut-être rien, mais si vous faites un infarctus,
le Samu va débouler, il va commencer à vous soigner sur place, et ça va vous faire gagner de précieuses minutes.
Bon, flippez pas hein, et puis vous servez pas de ça comme excuse pour pas faire de sport.
Si vous suivez ces conseils, si vous faites les choses bien,
il y aura pas de soucis.
*yeah*
Ca va même vous faire du bien,
parce qu'une activité physique régulière, ça permet d'éviter les infarctus.
D'ailleurs Churchill il en a fait un. Alors "no sport", hein...
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo, d'ici là tenez vos bonnes résolutions,
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous bien !